1987 рік.
Генеральний секретар ЦК КПРС Михайло Горбачов і президент США Рональд Рейган
підписують Договір про ліквідацію ракет середньої і меншої дальності.
Угода забороняє сторонам виробництво, випробування
і розгортання балістичних і крилатих ядерних ракет
наземного базування дальністю від п’ятисот до п’яти з половиною тисяч кілометрів.
Цей договір зіграв велику роль у завершенні гонки озброєнь у 80-ті роки і закінченні холодної війни.
Ми дотримувалися договору. Росія, на жаль, його не дотрималася.
Тож, ми збираємося розірвати угоду і вийти з неї.
Експерти вважають, що рішення Трампа вийти з одного з основних договорів
з контролю за ядерною зброєю продиктовано не тільки діями Росії.
США вже кілька років перебувають у стані масштабного геополітичного конфлікту з Китаєм.
І природно американська сторона дивиться, який баланс сил, наприклад, в сфері озброєнь.
Через договір про ракети середньої і меншої дальності
можливості США обмежені - так, їм заборонено виробництво балістичних
і крилатих ядерних ракет наземного базування
дальністю від п’ятисот до п’яти з половиною тисяч кілометрів,
в той час як Китай подібних обмежень не має.
У понеділок з візитом до Москви приїхав радник Трампа з національної безпеки Джон Болтон.
Ще у 2011 році він заявляв про необхідність розширення ядерного договору.
На його думку, угода обмежує можливості Вашингтона і Москви зміцнювати свій потенціал,
в той час як загроза гонки озброєнь все більше походить від інших країн, в тому числі від Китаю.
Ми змушені розробляти цю зброю.
Хіба що Росія та Китай прийдуть до нас і скажуть:
давайте зробимо розумно, і ніхто з нас не буде розробляти цю зброю.
Однак поки США заклопотані своїм протистоянням з Китаєм,
у Європі зростає серйозне занепокоєння діями американських партнерів.
Адже договір про ліквідацію ракет середньої і меншої дальності
до цього часу був однією з основ європейської безпеки.
Для європейської безпеки вихід США з цього договору - справжня катастрофа.
Адже Європа опиняється в дуже непростій ситуації.
З одного боку, вона не має важелів впливу на Росію і США.
Просто тому, що європейці не є стороною договору.
А з іншого боку, вихід США розв'яже руки Росії, яка зможе створювати стільки ракет, скільки захоче.
У цих ракет будуть якісь цілі, і ці цілі будуть десь у Західній Європі.
Тобто, захід Європи знову стає фокусом двостороннього ядерного протистояння.
Так само, як це вже було за часів "холодної війни".
У разі розірвання США ракетної угоди, з трьох договорів про роззброєння,
укладених у роки "холодної війни", залишиться тільки один -
договір про скорочення стратегічних наступальних озброєнь.
З договору про обмеження систем протиракетної оборони США вийшли ще у 2001 році.